дело в том что существует два типа
ошибок 13 пока ошибок это ошибки
понимания второй тип от ошибок и ошибки
поведения и вот ошибки понимания когда
люди думают что они инвестируют вот это
большая проблема когда они покупают
машину и думаю что
инвестирует вот эта большая проблема на
самом деле они не инвестируют они
создают будущее проблемы я приведу
пример один раз мой один товарищ пришел
и
купил зажигалку zippo золотую и
к котором катар который режет сигары на
стол положил я кругу крутая зажигалка
крутой которго рубли говорю на 5 штук
попал ты куда не какую-то штука даже 600
долларов ехать за 600 долларов купил
игру да это 600 долларов но смотри ты же
пришел ты же не в карман держал лишь
пришел на сторону что тоже изнаночной а
мы с ним друзьями это тоже значит что ты
это купил для того чтобы вот так на стол
брякнуть перед друзьями ну то есть
похвастаться так ведь ты же для этого
купил так но теперь ты это купил ты же
не может не куплю ни курить сигары это
ехать и горели в это же глупость
соответственно у тебя ты должен купить
сигару так так хорошо вот и он доставит
сигар фигуру смотрелось егор аромат
жилет дорогая davidoff у тебя игру этих
игр в которых к сатане ты заказываешь в
америке каждая сигара там сто пятьдесят
сто баксов это дорого так так ты же не
мог дешевые дешманский сигары сетевые
карты отделяем тем более все друзья же
разбирается
соответственно ты берешь обязательно
купить дорогую сигару хорошо дальше т.к.
1 купишь дорогую сигару ты же при нас не
можешь сигару просто курить сухомятку ты
же обязательно be scared купишь подножка
сигарами старый маг а ничё так вы
соответственно вот ты и будешь попадать
на вискарика и конечо дальше сигары ты
так как заказываешь с америки ты же не
поштучно закажешь а сразу много значит
нужно хранить сигары до этого how my
door аху medor стоит пожалуйста три
штуки баксов самый дешевый потому что
ящик для сигар который поддержит
влажность и температуру и так далее так
далее вот у тебя получается и ты
попадаешь на хуй door и вот когда я
посчитал это у меня выступить с клеем
6000 долларов ум вот так попал я вы
рассмотрите психологии бедных людей они
покупают вот такую зажигалку и думает
что все это зажигалка а самом деле эшли
это стоит 500 нам или 600 долларов на
самом деле это является триггером того
что ты попадешь на 6 штук вот это это
всегда вот нужно учитывать ты кстати я
это называется на владение этого термина
нигде нет я сам вывел цена владение в
моем понимании это когда ты в любую вещь
берешь и у тебя эта вещь за собой тащит
целый шлейф дополнительных расходов люди
сперва автомобиль это дорогое
обслуживание а да значит дорогие дорогов
сложные то дорогие покрышки зимние даже
не можно по заметила мультфильм холодное
сердце и пошли игрушек
игрушки то это еще не обязательная
это значит будет когда ты на холодное
сердце павел ребенка а потом потому что
если ты сам посмотрел ты не попадешь на
над и а если ты провел ребенка то ты
попадешь на это наша ребенка папа купит
и купили для купе еды и так далее
поэтому вот это ошибки
распространенные ошибки управление
финансами инвестирование и т.д. вот я
хотел бы вот поделитесь вы
какие вы видите ошибки у людей в части
управления финансами инвестиции у меня
даже больше они не ошибки я вот просто
смотрю в москве на блогеров да и
так как я сама журналист и плавно
перетекла мои профессиях блогерство да я
смотрю на них я хожу там на различные
тусовки я вижу что он не все ездят на
lamborghini до maybach при этом
я так примерно понимаю да сколько они
зарабатывают у нас вчера в той же
блогеры из астаны купили себе
rolls-royce я занимаюсь бизнесом да я
хорошо зарабатываю но я не могу себе
позволить купить роллс-ройс я вот думаю
это ради хайпа то есть они так делают
или же это как вы говорите да то есть
когда там потому что я как-то
разговаривал со своим другом диабетом
или вековым то он там на бинки катается
с 20 лет и не бегает как-то один раз
просто так обронил такую сразу что ты
знаешь сколько мне дверей открыл этот
bentley то есть иногда это вот это вот
цен овладение как вы говорите да то есть
ты покупаешь какую-то вещь которая может
быть еще больше внимания и еще больше
доходов тебе приносит ты хорошо сказал и
о том что то что касается
до для них это дне есть
расходы от рождения объект доходов то
есть это все ложь на животном на режим
надут в рекламу благодаря этому петли
они говорят смотрите вот я
купил дельты благодаря своим знанием
соответственно вот вы купите у меня мои
курсы и тогда мы тоже это по сути всего
что купить
но я тебе такое не позволяя живут во что
не продуешь курсы ним как заработать на
бы нет я понимаю что это тоже может быть
там а как реклама бы выглядела да ну я
все таки люблю жить соответственно своим
доходом да то есть я например допустим
январь это такой не самый лучший месяц
для бизнеса поэтому сегодня я пролетел
avast новая волна ту экономом понимаете
я если хорошо
зарабатываем бизнесом поэтому я да то
есть я могу конечно взять и купить себе
тоже rolls royce da но я понимаю что во
первых это дорого да во вторых ну я не
живу так чтобы кататься на устрой то
есть и считаю что должна четко расходы
строить под своим мне кажется нужно быть
вот в этом смысле реалистом и жить
позволяет мне мой заработок особенно
сейчас да вот когда он произошли в эти
январские события я задумалась что да у
меня есть активы но если бы там условно
алмату захватили тома станут примеру
захватили да там и мы остались в этом
условно без власти и
может быть там экономика бы достало то
чтобы я бы делала да например если не
могу срочно продать свою машину да то
есть ее никто не купит квартиру никто не
купит а то есть бизнес он просто
закройте все станет как пандемию я
впервые жизнь ввел как торговый центр мы
на новый год даже никогда на 31 декабря
не закрывая все закрылось я просто писал
что я должна делать то есть там пошла в
банк мне говорят вы можете 100000 только
then get a снять и в такие моменты ты
понимаешь что
очень важно
иметь новичку иметь вообще какой то не
знаю капитал или отъездом акции до
что-то что поможет тебе вот там
условностями взять уехать куда-то и что
то такое у тебя должно быть для того
чтобы ты такой force таких форс-мажорных
от качества что там уже довольно мире да
ну виртуальном мире я не знаю но что то
что у тебя где-то там не знаю храниться
до и ты можешь позволить себе куда-то
уехать и там пожить какое-то время не
работая да потому что мы же привыкли что
мы работаем мы молоды мы здоровы мы
можем заработать всегда мы верим что в
следующем месяце мы заработаем до своих
деньги а в такие моменты понимаю что ты
вообще
принадлежишь друзья как раз 1 aro
хорошие подняла вопрос это один из
лайфхаках тоже можете себе отметить дело
в том что когда мы говорим об
инвестиционной декларации когда мы
рассматриваем портфель инвесторы чему мы
обучаем мы обязательно смотрим такую-то
а если у человека финансовой подушки
потому что если у человека нету
финансовой подушки то он никогда не
будут успешными и месяцев это наличие
финансовой подушки важно не только в
вашей повседневной жизни но это важно и
для инвестирования потому что финансовая
подушка очень сильно влияет на то как вы
воспринимаете флуктуацию цен то есть на
вашу психологию очень сильно если вы на
последнем это знаете закон подлость и
все ты играешь на последняя тут и
огромная вероятно что ты потеряешь нет у
меня есть были деньги на карточку но я
просто поняла что я пришла дружба и мне
году можно снять деньги то есть тебя
ограничивают наши банки тебе говорят вне
повести там к спине работал да то есть
ты словно у тебя какие-то ограничения
стоят поэтому
не знают я поняла что вот как бы сумочки
туфли и прочее это конечно хорошо и там
я планировала еще много магазинов
открыть сейчас я поняла что нет такие
нужно очень прям распредели четко свои
яйца в разные корзины разложить и вот
этот год я посвящаю именно вот как вы
говорите да финансовым продлению именно
хочу все досконально
изучить эти инвестиции чтобы просто
таких в такой ситуации когда пандемия до
или вот такие события как в январе
произошли чтобы ты спокойно да не
переживай ты мог действительно взять и
куда-то уехать и там переждать у казахов
есть хорошая пословица вот именно к
этому событию что алтын к места sequin
art прогадай осыка то есть дословно
переводится что золото серебро это
камень а
пшеница и ячмень это еда ну насколько я
смог
но здесь сразу хочу еще второй лайфхак
подсказать
дело в том что вот твоя потребность в
наличных она помимо безопасности это
является еще и очень хорошим
инструментом управления личный интерес я
просто рекомендую если у вас проблемы с
управлениями управлением личными
финансами
снимите все де amis кэше заказа гроте
apple tv откажитесь от кредитных
карточек платите за все наличными
поверьте мне когда человек достает
наличными и платит у него психологически
совсем другой подход к хранить деньги и
[смех]
желательно все поддержать в кэше
рассчитываться в каше вопросы
бюджетирования это тоже есть когда ты
карточка оставь ты не понимаешь даже
дело в том что смотрите самый главный
лайфхак в управлении личными финансами
делайте все так чтобы платить
платить было сложно
apple pay кредитной карточки все дела на
облегчают жизнь завтра закрыта
достаточно дохода по и не может но
смотрите все вот эти купоны и дисконты
клубные карты и так далее все рассчитано
только на то чтобы облегчить вам
возможность оплаты кредитной карточки ты
а вы делать а наоборот максимально
усложняйте если вы хотите купить
какую-то вещь у вас в кармане оказалось
денег значит сама могу вам сказал не
покупая эту вещь но не доставайте
крыльев ну карточку и apple pay платите
за всем наличными это дополнительная
проблема ехать домой за деньгами пока ты
съездишь ты уже передумал думаешь затем
это покупать поэтому ну как бы такой
лайфхак